so i think a lot of people are
look at uh a brilliant person such as
yourself and
and are curious about the intellectual
journey they've took
um is there maybe three books
technical fiction philosophical that
had a big impact on your life that you
would recommend
perhaps others reading
yeah so um i actually didn't read that
much as a kid but i read
fairly voraciously now um
there are some recent books that if
you're interested in this kind of topic
like ai superpowers by kaifu lee is just
a fantastic read
you must read that um
yuval harari is just i think that
can open your mind um sapiens
sapiens as as the first one homo deuce
is the second yeah
i think we mentioned the black swan by
taleb i think that's a good
sort of mind opener i actually
um so
so there's maybe a more controversial
recommendation i could give um
great well i'd love something sure in
some sense it's
it's so classical it might surprise you
but i actually recently
read um mortimer adler's how to read a
book
not so long it was a while ago but some
people
hate that book i loved it
i think we're in this time right now
where
um boy we're just inundated with
research papers that you could read on
archive with
limited peer review and just this wealth
of information
i don't know i think the passion
of what you can get out of a book a
really good book or a really good paper
if you find it
the attitude the realization that you're
only going to find a few that really
are worth all your time but then
once you find them you should just dig
in and and and
understand it very deeply and it's worth
you know marking it up and and uh you
know having the hard copy
writing in the the side notes side
margins um
i think that was really it i read it at
the right time
where i was just feeling just
overwhelmed with
really low quality stuff i guess um
and similarly uh
i'm just giving more than three now i'm
sorry if i've exceeded my
my quota but on that topic just real
quick is uh
so basically finding a few companions
to keep for the rest of your life in
terms of papers and books and so on and
those are the ones like not doing um
what is it fomo fear missing out
constantly trying to update yourself
but really deeply making a life journey
of studying a particular paper
essentially
a set of papers yeah i think
when you really find something which a
book that resonates with you might not
be the same book that resonates with me
but when you really find one that
resonates with you i think the dialogue
that happens
and that's what i loved that adler was
saying you know i think
socrates and plato say um
the the written word is never gonna
capture
the beauty of dialogue right but adler
says no no
a a really good book is a dialogue
between you and the author
and it crosses time and space and
i don't know i think it's a very
romantic there's a bunch of like
specific advice which you can
just gloss over but the romantic view of
how to read and really
appreciate it is is is so good
and similarly teaching i uh um
i thought a lot about teaching and uh
and so
isaac asimov great science fiction
writer has also
actually spent a lot of his career
writing nonfiction right
his memoir is fantastic he
was passionate about explaining things
right he wrote all kinds of books on all
kinds of topics in science
he was known as the great explainer and
some you know i
i do really resonate with his style
and and just his way of
talking about you know by communicating
and explaining to something is
really the way that you learn something
i think
i think about problems very differently
because of the way
i've been given the opportunity to teach
them at mit
and we have questions asked you know the
fear of the lecture
the experience of the lecture and the
questions i get and the interactions
just forces me to be rock solid on on
these ideas in a way that
if i didn't have that i don't know i
would be in a different intellectual
space
also video does that scare you that your
lectures are online
and people like me and sweatpants can
sit sipping coffee and watch
once you give lectures that i think it's
great
i do think that something's changed
right now which is
you know right now we're giving lectures
over zoom
i mean giving seminars over zoom and
everything
um i'm trying to figure out i think it's
a new medium
do you think it's trying to figure out
how it is
yeah i've been um i've been quite
um cynical about the
human to human connection over over that
medium but i think
that's because it's hasn't been explored
fully and teaching is a different thing
every lecture is a
is a i'm sorry every seminar even i
think every talk
i give i i i you know there's an
opportunity to
give that differently i can i can
deliver content directly into your
browser you have a webgl
engine right there i could i can throw
3d
uh content into your browser while
you're listening to me
right yeah and i can assume that you
have a
you know at least a powerful enough
laptop or something to watch
zoom while i'm doing that while i'm
giving a lecture that that's a
that's a new communication tool that i
didn't have last year right and
i think robotics can potentially benefit
a lot from teaching that way
we'll see it's going to be an experiment
this fall i'm thinking a lot about it
yeah and also like um
the the length of lectures or the length
of like um
there's something so like i guarantee
you you know it's
like 80 of people who started listening
to our conversation
are still listening to now which is
crazy to me
but so there's a there's a patience and
a interest in long-form content
but at the same time there's a magic to
forcing yourself to condense an idea
to the shortest possible
uh shortest possible like clip it can be
part of a longer thing but like just a
really beautifully condensed idea
there's a lot of
opportunity there that's easier to do
and remote
with i don't know uh
with editing too editing is an
interesting thing
like what uh you know most professors
don't get
when they give a lecture you don't get
to go back and edit out parts
like chris like crisp it up a little bit
uh
that's also it can do magic like if you
remove like five to ten minutes from an
hour lecture
it can it can actually cr it can make
something special of a lecture i've uh
i've seen that in myself and and in
others too because i edit other people's
lectures to extract clips
it's like there's certain tangents
they're like that lose they're not
interesting they're
they're they're mumbling they're just
not they're not clarifying they they're
not helpful at all
and once you remove them it's just i
don't know
editing can be magic uh a lot of time
yeah it takes
it depends like what is teaching you
have to ask
yeah because i find the editing process
is also
beneficial as uh for teaching but
also for your own learning i don't know
if have you watched yourself
have you watched those videos it's i
mean not all of them okay
it could be painful yeah and to see like
how to
improve so do you find that uh i know
you segment your
um your podcast do you think that helps
people
with the the attention span aspect of it
or is it segment like sections like
yeah we're talking about this topic
whatever no nope that just helps me
it's actually bad so uh and you've been
incredible uh so i'm i'm learning like
i'm afraid of conversation this is
even today i'm terrified of talking to
you i mean it's something i'm
trying to remove from myself i there's
this
a guy i mean i've learned from a lot of
people but really
um there's been a few people who's been
inspirational to me in terms of
conversation
whatever people think of him joe rogan
has been inspirational to me because uh
comedians have been too being able to
just
have fun and enjoy themselves and lose
themselves in conversation
that requires you to be a great
storyteller
to be able to uh pull a lot of different
pieces of information together
but mostly just to enjoy yourself in
conversations and i'm trying to learn
that
these notes are you see me looking down
that's like a safety blanket that i'm
trying to let go of more and more
cool um so that's that people love just
regular conversation
that's that's what they the structure is
like whatever
uh i would say i would say maybe like 10
to like so there's a bunch of you know
there's uh probably
a couple thousand phd students listening
to this right now
right and they might know what we're
talking about
but there is somebody i guarantee you
right now
in russia some kid who's just like who's
just smoke some weed
is sitting back and just enjoying the
hell out of this conversation
not really understanding he kind of
wants some boston dynamics videos he's
just
enjoying it um and i salute you sir
uh no but just like there's a so much
variety of people
that just have curiosity about
engineering about sciences
about mathematics and um and also
like i should that i mean
enjoying it is one thing but i also
often notice it in
inspires people to there's a lot of
people who are like in their
undergraduate studies trying to figure
out
what uh trying to figure out what to
pursue and
those these conversations can really
spark the direction of their
of their life and in terms of robotics i
hope it does because uh
i'm excited about the possibilities for
robotic springs
you